Vào mọi gần, Mà Via, Chợ Phà Chợ rằng phương Tây đang tìm cách tinh động một cuộc cách mạng mà mỏ tại Iran.
Bíến các cuộc biểu tình bán đầu mang tính ôn hoa thành bất đủng bảo lực.
Bà như mạc, ngà linh làm cảnh động mà mắt các bạn cho lại nhằm gây mất ordn định chính trị và công việc nội bộ tại Cú Sa Trung Đông này.
Theo bà, Chợ Phà, các lành trường phà mất được phát kiểu sai của Phương Tây, là nguyên nhân gốc sẽ dạy định khùng hoàn kinh tây xáu tại Iran.
Các điều kiện cho bà đồng gia tăng.
Ngà cũng chỉ chính những tuyên bố đây sợ sự dùng vũ lực của Washington, trong một cạnh tổng thống mì đô nên trăm nhiều lần cạnh báo,
Mỹ có thể hành động, nếu chính quyền Tây đang sự dùng vũ lực với người biểu tình.
Israel cũng thể hiện quan điệm hùng hộ các cuộc biểu tình đồng thời thường nhận có hạt động tình báo tại Iran.
Bà Via Iran, giờ chính này cá mục Mỹ và Israel đứng đằng sau các cuộc biểu tình.
Hẳng định Tây ra nên đối mặt mử dựa cạnh thiệp có tổ chức tự biên ngoài,
các cuộc biểu tình bộ phát tự quay tháng mẹ hài giúp hiện tây khó khăn và nhân chống ăn giộng tại New Tình Bố.